hey what's up guys my name is echono
welcome back to devlog monday
it's thursday so for those of you not
know where this is a little series which
is essentially just a development log of
hazel my game engine
i am making a game engine which is uh
like i'm not gonna lie some pretty poor
life decisions
led to this moment but i am doing it and
i don't know what else to do so here no
i'm getting jokes aside i really do like
working on this stuff and i have some
pretty exciting stuff to show you today
that is mostly thanks to the community
now a few months ago a man by the name
of karim
messaged me and said that he had to do
an internship as part of his university
studies
and he was wondering if he could do it
for hazel
with me and i was like absolutely now
karim is very interested in graphics and
actually one of the things that he kind
of presented me with which was his
product for university and also kind of
like as a pitch
was essentially a version of hazel that
he had kind of
made into his own game engine which had
a lot more rendering features he had
basically used it like as his final
university project
now this engine had like deferred
rendering it had like
all these various effects like screen
space ambient occlusion a bit of screen
space reflections you know all of this
stuff so it was a lot more fancy
than kind of the rendering features that
were available in hazel at the time and
so karim joined the hazel core team
for three months and i'm about to show
you what he's been working on he's been
primarily working
as a kind of rendering engineer so since
karim joined us as someone working on
rendering
he asked me what i wanted him to do and
i mean there's so many rendering things
that i want to do
but i knew that the first thing that we
need to really be able to handle is
lights i mean that makes sense right at
the moment in hazel we've just been
using like forward rendering
based basic old classic forward
rendering which basically just means
that you have a piece of geometry
you render it and right then and there
you just shade every pixel and you do
every lighting calculation now most
engines
these days use something called deferred
rendering deferred rendering basically
just means that instead of doing that
actual lighting calculation right there
in 3d space with all of your geometry as
you render it for the first time
you basically don't do that instead what
you do is during those kind of 3d
geometry passes you just simply gather
information about the geometry such as
like what is it what materials is it
using where is it in the world like
what are the normals where is it facing
all of that you gather that into a bunch
of textures and then you just do your
actual shading
kind of in screen space on just a quad
that way
you don't have to waste time like
calculating all this different shading
for different things where lights might
not be
in that specific area or maybe it's been
like overwritten by another piece of
geometry there's a lot of benefits
however because you are kind of faking
this like i like to call deferred
rendering fake rendering because
you're not actually rendering stuff in
3d space i mean you are to generate
those buffers in the first place with
all the data that you need
but at the end of the day you're just
actually doing your shading on a
quad and because that's happening it
introduces a lot of issues a lot of them
do have fixes but
i guess conceptually for me it's far
from
ideal so what i told karim to do instead
was to look into forward plus rendering
so i'm not going to explain four plus
rendering in this video i mean you'll
see some of it in action
but forward plus rendering is a little
bit different it's basically
forward rendering that's kind of why
it's called ford plus by the way it has
a lot of names like
clustered forward shading tiled forward
shading
there's a lot like volume tiled forward
shading there's a lot of different names
for it
but essentially what it does is it
reduces
the amount of pixels that have to
process certain lights
thereby optimizing your lights so
essentially what happens is the screen
gets divided into tiles
and these tiles are not just kind of
like x and y tiles but they're actually
they have depth as well they're
basically these little volumes
kind of like voxels but we won't get
too much into that and before we do any
actual like shading and figuring out
what what color like
these meshes that we're drawing in our
scene are we have this pass where we go
through and we work out
what tiles are affected by what lights
and so what happens is
that data is then used to make it so
that we are not processing an excessive
amount of lights per pixel
if you still have like a thousand point
lights on top of each other
and they're all kind of affecting the
same pixels then of course you will
still be slow
but in a real kind of big 3d world like
a scene this huge scene
you can literally have like thousands of
lights and
it's not really going to affect your
performance that much because for any
given kind of group of pixels that
you're rendering
you're only dealing with the local
lights that are in that specific area
and as i mentioned
this works in 3d space because it like
uses these volumes essentially so what
that means is that
if something is in front of the camera
that's obscuring the vision of
other kind of fragments that are in the
background they're not going to
they're not going to be doing any
lighting calculations anyway this is a
lot easier to actually show
and kind of demonstrate you know
visually so let's jump into
hazel and take a look so it looks pretty
much the same but now what we can do is
we can create a point light
and when we create a point light i added
this icon by the way
like 30 minutes ago on stream twitter tv
slash the turner by the way is my live
stream i
stream like i don't really have a
schedule but every now and then when i'm
working i'll just throw up a stream
and so this is what i was doing today
basically adding these icons and playing
around with a with a
like with a few visualization settings
which you'll see in a minute so
basically we have this point light um we
have a few options here like we can
change the color
for example so i can make it like red we
have an intensity
we have a minimum radius we have a
radius and we like the radius is just
like basically
how big the light is and we have a
falloff which kind of tweaks the
fall-off
uh like the way that it does fall off
it's pretty subtle at the moment we're
still
kind of working out what parameters we
actually want to have but this is
basically the way that it works for now
so if i um kind of reduce this maybe
move this up here you know we can
start to play around with this i can
duplicate it i can set the color to
something like blue now we have like a
nice little
uh kind of pink in the middle as the two
lights kind of intertwine
anyway that's the basic idea and i mean
like there's
you know a lot of stuff you could
obviously do with this um
you can have a lot of these lights i
mean at the moment we've actually
limited it to 1000
per scene but that's not like it doesn't
need to be 1000 it can be
realistically we could as long as
they're not in the same place we could
probably render like a million of these
um so it's pretty nice and obviously if
i like drop into this
world and then you can see everything
running as usual
the audio is playing and this is kind of
our normal scene
so um you know in terms of how it works
point lights themselves
are pretty simple um but the benefit
here obviously as i mentioned is the
fact that this is all kind of
uh you know these lights are culled
according to how much kind of range i
guess they take up
and also where they are in the world
meaning that like when we actually
physically shade these pixels we don't
have to worry about like oh there's a
light next to it because if it's not
affecting it then we're not doing the
lighting calculations we don't really
care about that
we're calling it kind of before the
shader even sees any of this
so i've actually added an option over
here it's a little bit difficult to see
but it's over here it's called show
light complexity and so if i turn that
on what you'll actually see is this
little view so
this shows you the tiles which is pretty
nice to see
because you can actually see the tiles
they're 16 by 16 pixel tiles
um and what this what this mode is
intended for
basically showing you is the complexity
of your lights
for a given pixel that you're actually
rendering so you can see that these
this kind of area over here is just not
lit by any point lines that's why it's
kind of the normal color
but then as we get kind of into a more
complex
area basically meaning that there are
more lights affecting that pixel it
basically it's kind of like a heat map
it gets closer to red
so if i let's actually kind of start
over if i delete all these lights
let's add a point light i'll make it
kind of
the radius kind of small so maybe like
three or so meters
i'll move it over here and yeah it looks
a bit weird when you look at it this way
um obviously without this it kind of
looks like a normal point light
you can see it's kind of affecting like
the cube a little bit but this shows you
what it's really affecting
and then if i duplicate this right then
you can kind of see where the lights
overlap now of course this is kind of
dependent on their radius the smaller
the light the less it overlaps that
makes sense right
um you'll also see a little bit of
overlapping from the underside because
of course it is a point light
um so like there's no kind of like you
know the pixels
they don't know that there's stuff kind
of obstructing them but of course if you
were to move this
up sufficiently high then if you look at
it on the other underside you can see
i'm only actually seeing
that kind of other one the second one
not the first one um
and another good example actually is
that if this light
over here we can't click on them yet
which is a little bit annoying
if this light was like behind this
sphere over here for example
then you can see if the sphere is
actually in the way you know
we're not rendering those that that
light kind of isn't being rendered it's
not being calculated because there's a
sphere obscuring the pixels that are
behind the sphere that are lit
so it's pretty clever in that sense um
so okay so let's talk about the light
complexity so if i basically um
have a bunch of these you can see as i
start as i keep duplicating them
we wind up with spots that are slightly
more complex now at the moment the scale
is a bit
i don't know i just made it up basically
16 li at 16 lights it will be red
so if i just basically keep duplicating
it you can see that eventually we get to
red and red just means that hey man
you've got a lot of lights in the same
place
which basically means you might want to
reduce that because it might cause
performance issues you can see it's
totally fine running over here
no problem at all but um might be
something you think about i haven't not
really done too many performance
benchmarks i know that we can handle
like thousands of lights
uh like at 60fps and that's totally fine
but if they're all in the same spot i'm
not sure what that is like really
but yeah so let's open up something a
little bit more interesting just for fun
like sponsor and then we can try adding
a bunch of point lights
and seeing how they affect the scene
okay so what i've done here is just
added a bunch of kind of multi-colored
lights
uh again if we turn on that light
complexity then you can see
what's going on here um they've got
pretty they've got like four meter
ranges so
you can see they're even hitting the
taurus over here um and then the other
thing is you can actually kind of access
this light complexity during actual
gameplay as well so if we
um drop into the world and we take a
look at you know all these
nice lovely lights we can turn on that
light complexity
and now you can see that you know
because obviously it's going to be
different for the editor when you see
like
everything from above it's important to
actually visualize it what it's like
during
you know actual gameplay and you can see
here that we can uh kind of see what's
going on
with all the lights so yeah pretty cool
i think this visualization mode is
really cool because it lets you actually
see
how it works kind of it helps with um
actually uh understanding how forward
plus rendering works
but then also it's obviously useful for
debugging maybe slow
kind of areas in your scene where the
cost of
kind of calculating those those
fragments those pixels
can be a little bit expensive because
there's just a lot of lights
in the same kind of place anyway i hope
you guys enjoyed this video if you did
please don't forget to hit the like
button below
we're getting all these really cool
tools um you know now we can have point
lights um i haven't added spotlights yet
but that's on my list as well
um so we're getting all these tools and
it's i honestly haven't even had a
chance to
use this much um to actually build
scenes
so i'm really excited to be able to do
that um and going forward again
hopefully i'll be able to show you guys
some more exciting scenes than simply
like this sponsor demo
if you have any questions please leave
them in the comment section below again
a huge shout out to karim of course
because he was the person that did the
majority like 95
of the work to get it into this state
karim's internship is coming to an end
and unfortunately i can't afford to hire
him
full-time so he's asked me to mention
that if anyone has
any work or any leads for him any kind
of job opportunities then please let him
know
i can definitely recommend him i think
he's done some amazing work on hazel
if you would like to support hazel's
development you can go to patreon.com
the churno and you'll receive access to
all of this lovely source code
thank you all for watching have a great
rest of your day and i will see you next
time goodbye
[Music]
you